Hello, and welcome back to the lab where we take your questions and turn them into experiments
My name is Mitch - and I'm Greg and what if I told you that there was a list of questions that could make you
fall in love with a stranger
Well it turns out there was actually a study done where they took a specific set of 36 questions
had two complete strangers
ask them to each other and it increased the likelihood that they would fall in love
And obviously in general just doing one experiment doesn't prove anything
But we thought it would be awesome to get to strangers in here, forced them to do this experiment and see what happened
So this is what happened. - My name is Cam, and I'm 24. - My name is Emily, and I'm 22 years old
I'm nervous about today to be perfectly honest. - I really want to see if the study works
I think it'll be, you know, what if we hate each other or we don't like what we're saying
I I think it'll be cool to see if it's effective. -Hey, how's it going? -Great, how are you? -Good. Emily, right? -Yes, Cam. -Cool
Very nice to meet you. - Yeah, nice to meet you too. Are you
Nervous at all for this? -Yes. -Yeah me too. We can just get started. So the first question
Given the choice of anyone in the world who would you want as a dinner guest?
Instinctually I want to say Clint Eastwood
Nice
I would say probably like Neil Armstrong or something like that. Think I would
Like to be famous, I guess. Not an a-list celebrity or anything like that
Maybe a D-list one, where some people will know who you are. You know, you'd be that guy
I sung to myself on the car ride over here. I was listening to Taylor Swift. - Nice, what song? - The whole album
Oh nice. - And like Fearless not even her new stuff, so - They're keeping the questions pretty light as you could see it
I used to think I was gonna die really young like in high school when I was angsty I was like
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna..? That's gonna happen, but then I hit 18 and I was like forget that Emily
You're gonna live to a hundred you're making the century club. - I've always wanted to be a good artist
I'd like to be maybe a bit more
Assertive
Maybe not too much so though. I don't want to push people into doing anything
They don't want to do
My most terrible memory was the morning my sister called me to tell me that my mom had had a heart attack
Yeah, she's okay
Ok it's good that she's okay, but I can imagine that is terrifying. - Yeah, that was a bad memory. - She's doing... She's
Yeah, she's doing well. She's doing very well. - I would say mine
would be when
My Grandma's mind just kind of started deteriorating
Because she lived with us for
my whole life you know to see her forget who I am and you know call me a different name and
She would wake up some days
And you know and she's a 90 year old woman and wonder why she didn't have school. That whole
Part is pretty terrible. I would say so
That would be really hard
I know people need affection and I do too
But I have to like more think about sometimes my actions people need validation sometimes and they need to hear that or see
You by touch stuff like that. Romantic love hasn't been a big role in my life for the past
A little over a year now. I'm
trying to
Be a bit more cautious about who I give and receive that love from because it is so important
I have a stuffed animal Buster. He's a dog
So I
probably might save
Buster. - Mine's Fluffy, he's also... - Oh, ok. Buster & Fluffy should meet one day
I was worried about this coming into it because I can be a little bit awkward
But you make me feel at ease. - You know you seem very cool and calm and very confident at the same time
so I guess that's
Three but yeah you have a... you definitely have a good personality. - I also like what you're wearing
oh, thank you - I think those colours really compliment you and
Make you look handsome. - Cool, thank you. - You're welcome
Um I like your face, it's a nice face. - Your face is very symmetrical which...
- Nice. - Is something
We subconsciously look for but because I know that I consciously look for - I say like a lot like like this like that
But you're very very well spoken. - I actually swear all time. I'm trying really hard - Shit
Fuck, alright, curse like a sailor? - yeah. - it would be nice
To have someone that you could literally
Say anything and everything and they would still
Like you and respect you and not think you're a big weirdo. You have a very very nice smile. I would definitely make out with you
Okay, yeah, I was kind of thinking about that like on our break. I was like yeah, I would definitely make out with him
Yeah, I think he's pretty attractive. We have a lot of things in common, and I like what I like
so it was a good thing. I think it's a good thing that you know kind of a lot of stuff in common
I expected it to be a lot more awkward, but it was it was more just exciting. - Hmm, yeah, I like you. You're cool.
Yeah, thank you
Uh yeah, I was interesting getting to know a lot about you because a lot of those questions aren't necessarily stuff
You'd say right away or even sometimes ever to someone
Yeah, I would like to see him again. - okay um and if you guys want to, and there is no pressure
You guys can kiss if you would like
Sure
Sounds good
Okay you guys, so maybe we'll follow up in like a few months